staying in the legal realm the nfl has
an initiative called inspire change so
far so good change can be very good
or not
some of the money donated by the nfl has
gone to groups who want to defund the
police and abolished prisons and i don't
think that reflects the values and
beliefs of most americans or
quite frankly most nfl players
i met with current and former nfl
players when i was in congress and it
was a very productive meeting these
players were knowledgeable on the
challenges within our justice system we
discussed mandatory minimum prison
sentences and reentry programs and
proportionality and sentencing on these
issues there is consensus
but how do you get from that to
defunding the police and abolishing
prison
the nfl is an entity that will fine you
for having your shirttail out
the nfl will find you for wearing the
wrong socks
literally they find players for
violating the dress code
the nfl penalizes you if you breathe too
hard on a quarterback or
hurt the quarterback's feelings
touch a referee and you're gone for a
long time you know what happens if you
throw a punch in the nfl you go to their
version of prison
there are more cops on an nfl football
field than anywhere else in the country
they're just called referees
do you know what happens if you even
criticize a referee
you get fined
so why would a league built on rules and
punishment want to eliminate the people
who enforce our rules and our
punishments
the nfl literally finds cd lamb because
his shirttail came out and they want to
complain about bond being set for people
accused of committing really serious
crimes
lay aside how incongruent the nfl's
actions are with what most of their fans
want nfl fans don't want to defund the
police or abolish prison
it's the hypocrisy of building a league
based on rules and penalties and
referees and punishment and then wanting
to do away with that on the larger
playing field of life
the nfl's decision to fund groups that
advocate for things nfl fans players and
supporters do not want
is a curious one
my guess is the folks in the stands and
buying the merchandise and paying for
the nfl channel will be surprised to
learn their money is going for crazy
things like defunding the police and
abolishing prison
you want to defund the police and
abolish prison
prove it
get rid of your own referees
throw out the rule book i mean after all
god forbid someone's shirttail comes out
we can't have that kind of crime
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else